six months ago matt damon told us all
that fortune favors the brave in a
commercial that appeared to be about
sailing flying and rocket ships but was
actually about a crypto exchange the
implication of course being if you don't
buy into crypto in 2022 you're a chicken
a coward and you're gonna be crying to
your grandkids trying to explain why
they can't eat because you didn't listen
to the janitor from goodwill hunting my
boy's awakened smile and this was the
beginning of a major spending spree for
the crypto exchange called crypto.com
they were going to do things differently
while other people bribed celebrities
like jimmy fallon with pictures of apes
crypto.com was going to be smart and
judicious about their spending which is
why they spent 100 million dollars on
this ad comparing going to mars with
buying crypto and they followed it up by
buying the naming rights to the staples
center for 700 million dollars now i
know what you're thinking 800 million
that's a lot of money to spend just on
ads but fear not they have a great
revenue business plan they're going to
make money on trading fees and also on
people investing in their coin called
chronos or crow but of course getting
people to go to your website is one
thing and getting them to invest in your
token is quite another so to make this
happen crypto.com hatched a plan they
were going to give an insane offer a
debit card which gave you eight percent
cash back on all purchases they would
pay for your netflix account they pay
for your spotify subscription amazon
prime they would even put you in a
private jet partnership if you bought a
lot of their crypto and promised not to
sell it by locking it up also known as
staking the more you staked the more you
earned with their tiered system they had
several cards on offering the top one
being the obsidian card they advertised
it gave you eight percent back on all
purchases instantly all you have to do
to get it is invest hundred thousand
dollars into the crypto.com token and
stake it for like six months or
something now of course if you're too
poor for that you can try their lower
tiers like the icy white or jade
collection in both cases you get
slightly less rewards for paying a lot
less money but if this is starting to
sound like a ponzi scheme locking
outrageous sums of money into a system
to get outrageous returns we haven't
even gotten to the best part which are
the staking rewards the other part of
this whole scheme is that while you
staked kronos coin you made kronos coin
apparently they were giving 12
per year extra in chronos to people who
staked kronos that's in addition to the
subscriptions they're paying for eight
percent cash back
all of this stuff all you have to do to
get all of it is be brave like matt
damon says and give them 400 000 for a
while so that's the plan in a nutshell
what could possibly go wrong
oh
oh oh crypto.com slumps 30 of staking
rewards are slashed crypto.com soon
after assembling everyone in their
website for this flagship marketing
campaign kind of was like
yeah uh we're actually
not gonna do that because it's
unsustainable in in their words because
you know all these crypto arenas they
have to buy they they don't exactly have
the money for it so as of may 1st they
took all the cards and basically
obliterated the rewards here's the
change on screen you can see things like
obsidian and icy got their rewards
obliterated now understandably they're
investors who staked incredible amounts
of money into their crow coin were
completely pissed off about this because
not only is their card in most cases
nearly worthless also the price of their
crow which is locked up and they can't
sell began to plummet right after this
news was announced here's some quotes
from their reddit so i staked for indigo
at the peak because of the three percent
cashback made it worth it micro is down
over 50
and now they're slashing the cashback
rates wow so basically people lost money
on their staked money while also having
the ability to get cash back slashed but
the people in charge of crypto.com
clearly felt like they were between a
rock and a hard place on the one hand
they had promised unsustainable things
and spent their money on advertising on
the other hand
they might go bankrupt because the price
of their token is going to zero and it
was at this point the ceo decided to
backpedal and give something back to the
community he said in a comment quote the
community has always been really vocal
with regards to the changes to the card
program announced yesterday we care
deeply about the community and we'll
always hear you and always listen to you
as a result we're revising card staking
rates it was at this point they gave a
small concession back to the community
they were going to re-implement the
staking at a slightly lower rate but
from the reaction it wasn't quite enough
this guy says didn't know we were
haggling for price at the fish market
did we haggle to have a different stake
amount when we applied for the crow card
no we didn't and couldn't and here we
have crypto.com spending millions on
advertising now haggling with us on the
rates so if we didn't make noise you
would have just sliced us and diced us
the answer to that of course is yes
definitely yes and the worst part of all
of this is that even after wrecking
people on this sort of bait and switch
deal crypto.com is still advertising
their eight percent cashback rates even
now and so what's the lesson here well
as kind of trite as it sounds the real
lesson is that if it sounds too good to
be true
matt damon will promote it anyways and
by the way crypto.com ceo chris uh that
guy you should probably know before
starting this crypto exchange he left
his last job quote amid accusations from
customers and business partners that
they had been ripped off but if that's
not bad enough check this out one
business owner quote claimed chris's
platform had issued promotions to boost
its revenue just before shutting down
deals that were then left worthless so i
don't know maybe you should add that in
your commercial next time what does matt
damon say on that bitcoin commercial
fortune favors the brave my dad said he
listened to matt david and lost all his
buddy yes everyone did but they were
brave in doing so